In 2021, over 360,000 people left California...
...in what many are calling the "California exodus,"...
...leaving for states like Texas, Arizona, and Washington.
But a rising number of them are migrating out of the country altogether,...
...and instead heading south of the border.
Today, more and more Americans are leaving the hustle and bustle of California...
...for a relaxed, more affordable lifestyle in Mexico.
We were able to cut our budget in half,...
...which allowed us to really focus on our careers,...
...and the things we wanted to do artistically without having to just like,...
...hustle and hustle and hustle every day, every week, every month...
...to just meet the bare minimum.
California's population growth has been declining for over 30 years now,...
...but thanks to the rise in remote work,...
...due to the Covid-19 pandemic, those trends have accelerated.
The ability to work anywhere has 62 percent of Americans considering moving to a new country.